like I'll get like I'll get some hey
obviously one of my oh you're easier to
hate it well I mean like I know you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
know I've hiked let me see this is so
yeah you know you just heard you dilute
like Brendan I live now I'm just taking
guy that's kind of mean no we're here
ching-chong right I'm so glad we're here
we can really just kind of get it out we
get all out there yeah yeah because I
honestly this is not even a bit
I feel tension with you guys no yeah a
little bit yeah no you give them my
girlfriend [ __ ] guys wow dude well I
hate to say this everyone gives your
girlfriend [ __ ] guys
hey come on take it easy stop giving him
you're giving him serious eyes you're
giving an accusation eyes my body do a
hard restart I got your little Harley
Bobby you don't want a guy just now I
felt that and I felt but here's the
thing though that's I get mad that you
drive a Ferrari and people look at it
yeah you know it sign up drive Ferrari
also girls girls want amazing job that's
you're smart girls when I mate with shop
in their instinct their instinct a lot
of times I see giant the giant yeah yeah
a dress like candy yeah yeah he's shiny
and he's also I want you to take that
hat off that you send pictures of us in
oh yeah are you talking about my my
Johnny Depp hat yeah yeah just be a
giant powerhouse don't know I respect
him saying no in your face like that I
like that a lot
no but I think there's a lonely
incinerator somewhere and I think that
it needs that hat and I agree you throw
that away
it's fine you're an artist okay
VRR say to get you are an artist tell
you sorry I'll never say it again but
here's the deal
if you can tell someone's that artist
from here yeah yeah yeah kill them
yeah yeah yup if I have Johnny Depp in
there right now he begged if you're not
Johnny Depp bro you're too big I don't
wear the same shoes now you're those
guys need to get a different wardrobe
period don't worry who they are I don't
care if you're I don't care how many
awards you want I don't care how good
yard acting don't wear all that goddamn
jewelry ring boy is that bring up let me
up Jared Leto Julie no I'm good so you
in the tundra bye
I agree don't wear a scarf when it's
breezy
agree agree he's a beautiful Jared
Leto's beautiful
what do you mean rest up like the Joker
it looked like it was just Tuesday for
him bye-bye yeah you know he's a
beautiful man and talented his [ __ ] but
he almost gets respect but not him no
that's the wrong argument the argument
is don't wear that right not him what
the [ __ ] is what's wrong with a nice hat
he's known the fifth he's got he's
Goldman more has beautiful gangster the
beautiful don't worry about Capone he's
a he wears hats a beautiful you don't
lift 600 pounds for reps you're a bold
giant bull Giants are not allowed to
wear dainty has quite a long argument we
could out Capone what you can make fun
Al Capone well yours is Al Capone well
is Al Capone yeah that face the other
went one of the other gangsters wear
half drive your metro and art is taken
kind of look at that yes it's tilted to
the side he's arguing about this all
wrong so what's our you make Chris don't
wear it period why there's no this guy
that guy you were a ball cap or you wear
no hat and maybe you wear a [ __ ] ski
out if it's cold out agree she's like 21
Jump Street you look how you got [ __ ]
up on 21st Avenue dude you look like
Lenny from of mice and Massimo you got
it will not retire from Hot Topic
did you locate the 50 year old vegan bro
get your life together man you came back
from Nashville and you changes you have
a thing in this car a blue thing though
you can't park anywhere handicap I don't
want to say that because yeah what are
those uh nope okay that I just parked
wait I know what you're saying I know
what you're [ __ ] saying oh yeah this
is so [ __ ] me what do I say
you say you're suggesting that he has
he has a learning problem that he looks
like he's a little bit mentally
challenged really that's what you
[ __ ] cuz you looked at him and you go
your your face or something now why is
your voice getting hot now that's where
you're going with this where were you
going with it what yeah what did you
mean by I'm missing a little bit of uh
dude I'll tell you why
did I tell you why you can't and I never
said this no you can't oh I know what it
is he looks like George from mysen man
yes hello Lenny look young I killed any
white dude that size with that big of a
head he'll demand what you say when you
say a brandon and he turns around and
his eyes do this a little bit and you're
like oh there's something wrong like Oh
a couple of things yeah oh my god like
dude that's not nice let's go let's call
up your girl see what she's like oh whew
let's talk like this let's call up your
girl see what she thinks
let's go up your home [ __ ] my girls no
this is real friendship Ryan and Brenda
do you guys look like the this is
America bro [ __ ] you're black you're
wearing black what do you got some
Egyptians from Long Island we're 19
different color
hey you got a bouncer at a TGI Fridays
and be confident I'm kind of dressed up
like levar ball today like how old do
you man yeah man now all there's no know
what when I stepped out of my purple
Porsche today I thought [ __ ] you Brendan
[ __ ] you bro do you have on right now
Stone wash like I didn't you're getting
too gassed up on your e-channel dude let
me let me tell you sometime gonna work
it in a hot minute
I'll gated though okay but check this
out check this out oil careful I work
for Bravo Bravo
I know that you're those your boys and
I'm gonna tell you something right now
Delaney
don't make me make Andy Cohen go bad on
your name tag we're good we're good
we know we're good - okay we're good -
and then I shave one tax what one one
tax and one tax and why yeah you know it
is a lot of people have a lot of people
probably want to have want to bed him
down at Bravo but from what I've seen I
would nobody's all that bed him down at
Bravo and Ian oh he's like the fighter
and he's got like he's like I'm a
fighter I haven't find 10 years yet I
still have this [ __ ] I do like the new
rookie on the big like T on the can
Italian leg oh yeah I think of that 30
no kid has pants back did I enjoy my
life just if you don't travel he goes to
tropical place it comes out that's what
was behind him that was behind his face
the whole time about he doesn't even
deserve one career come here and you
tell stories you can put a little what a
meathead you can you sure
you know I mean I was right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]